[Musique]
martin est à saint jérôme
elle veut avertir sa famille à montréal
qu'elle arrivera en retard mais son
cellulaire est mort elle aperçoit une
cabine téléphonique
elle n'a pas de monnaie mais
heureusement elle peut payer avec sa
carte de crédit
son appel est bref juste le temps de
dire qu'elle est retardé
c'est l'entreprise oi imac tel qu'il lui
envoie la facture belle lui a délégué la
gestion des appels interurbains à partir
d'un téléphone public avec une carte de
crédit
lorsqu'elle reçoit son compte martin a
une bien mauvaise surprise - mattel vie
réclame non pas 57 parfum ou 5 dollars
mais bien 18 dollars et elle n'a pas de
recours pour contester cette facture
parce que les appels interurbains fait à
partir d'une cabine téléphonique ne sont
plus réglementée il n'y a donc aucune
limite de prix au moment de l'appel
martin aurait dû prendre le temps
d'écouter le message d'accueil
l'informant des tarifs mais elle était
pressée et surtout jamais elle ne se
serait douté qu'un simple appel allait
coûter si cher
le fin mot de l'histoire dans les
cabines téléphoniques plus que jamais la
parole est d'argent
alors méfiez vous